le pearl est la structure la plus
sophistiqués au monde mais c'est
difficile de prévoir ce qui arriverait
en cas de problème antunez ma famille
est à l'intérieur ne s'arrêtait pas pour
tourner pas
je vous retrouverai
cette banque ça fait dix ans que j'ai
pas touché énorme après ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit là dedans
j'ai comme qui dirait rengaine aimons
colts mais sans ce coup du sort vous
allez vous en sortir
je n'aurais jamais connu ça j'aurais
jamais mes enfants papa m qui a pas une
qui je t'aime tu as intérêt
monsieur hire vous êtes la toute
première famille que nous accueillons
dans la partie résidentielle de pearl à
l'issue de votre audit de sécurité
que pensez vous de la tour de pearl et
la structure ultra haute la plus
sophistiqués au monde
c'est une prouesse technologique mais
c'est difficile de prévoir ce qui
arriverait en cas de problème
[Musique]
salut les gars
que ça brûle le 96e est en feu sarah
écoute moi le feu va progresser tous
devaient monter ne vous arrêtez pas ne
vous retournez pas ok on tue les gones
on attendait ma famille est à
l'intérieur
tournez-vous
surtout regarde pas en bas
c'était pas mal hein
moi je me suis jetée d'une grève
voilà l'homme que nous cherchions cette
tour protège quelque chose que je fais
et tu va me rapporter rien est
impossible quand on est motivé
non
ensemble on y croit j'ai peur
c'est normal d'avoir peur
pour être courageux avant il faut avoir
un petit peu peur
on doit sortir de cette tour tu veux
bien être courageux pour moi ouais pas
paniquer mois
[Musique]
oh